the american academy of pediatrics put
out an article suggesting that the
masking of child caregivers won't have
an impact on children's speech and
language development because there's no
known study on masking impacting a
child's speech and language development
was this capture or am i missing
something yeah i saw this this is this
is quite a feat of
linguistic verbal
acrobatics
but it's also prescriptive
what's that because it suggests that if
we can prevent anyone from doing a study
that demonstrates harm to children from
the masking of their caregivers
again there won't be any harm it's
exactly the same thing over and over and
over again yeah no evidence
no evidence yet exists means there can
be no evidence of harm means no evidence
means no harm i think the way to put it
is this
absence over and over and over again the
same sense of evidence means hey look
over there
yeah no but absence of evidence doesn't
mean hey look over there absence of
evidence means hey we're planning a flag
on this yeah we now know for sure that
this thing that we're telling you to do
is a hundred percent safe
like really do you well there aren't any
studies saying otherwise are there and
we're not gonna let any studies happen
and like you you wouldn't in this case
you know you wouldn't why because uh you
don't intentionally put children through
that hell yeah
yeah i mean
how could a professional group of
pediatricians and you know it was
probably an intern who wrote that
article whatever but
how can people whose professional life
is based
on
growing children into functional adults
with this by maximizing health
conclude
that not seeing other people's faces
early in childhood
is fine
and there won't be any harm
and
it's not even like the proposal is
well you know what if kidney function is
impaired like yeah i don't i can't
imagine an effect on kidney function but
language development
all of us read lips like even those of
us with no hearing impairment whatsoever
we all read lips yesterday
in oregon or at least in multnomah
county i think all of oregon we went
back to mandatory mass mandates inside
so yesterday for the first time in a
couple of months i was
yelling
at the butcher behind the meat canner
and he was yelling back at me because we
could not understand that what i
actually said was i want a tri-tip and
he was like do we have tri-tip like i
just want to try tip please and you know
we're laughing about it you could tell
we were laughing because we were
actually laughing so you could see it in
our eyes but we're like yeah we're back
here where we can't communicate where
miscommunication is right and we better
be gentle with one another because
suddenly we're back to where we cannot
in any way just
read the bottom half of a person's face
and know what they mean so yeah blocking
that information from children as
they're learning how to be humans that
won't have any costs
yeah that won't have any costs this
makes me so [ __ ] angry
don't trust anyone over nine
maybe do it again he wasn't on you yet
don't trust anyone over nine
[Music]
all right yeah yeah
yeah a compelling response yeah i mean i
think anger is not a compelling response
but
these people
these people
um
i i have i have a perfect a perfect way
of describing them that i am saving for
my next rap battle
and
your first one
yeah also my first but possibly quite
possibly my last one
[Music]